Variační kvantový eigensolver neboli VQE je jedním z nejstarších hybridních kvanto-klasických algoritmů a je
zajímavý z několika důvodů. Za prvé, jak uvidíme v tomto videu, je to slibný přístup pro některé typy problémů. Za druhé, je důležitý
historicky a vydláždil cestu mnoha vylepšeným algoritmům, jako je adapt VQE.
A konečně, VQE je poměrně jednoduchý. Je snadné pochopit, co dělají kvantové a klasické počítače v tomto algoritmu
a jak spolu interagují. VQE výpočet má čtyři hlavní komponenty.
Za prvé, existuje operátor, často Hamiltonián, který budeme nazývat H, který popisuje vlastnost systému, kterou
chceš optimalizovat. Jiný způsob, jak to říct, je, že hledáš eigenvector tohoto operátoru, který
odpovídá minimální eigenhodnotě. Tento eigenvector často nazýváme základní stav.
Dále existuje ansatz – německé slovo znamenající přístup. Toto je kvantový circuit, který připravuje kvantový stav přibližující
eigenvector, který hledáš. Ansatz je vlastně rodina kvantových circuit, protože některé gate v
ansatz jsou parametrizované. To znamená, že jsou jim předány parametry, které můžeme měnit. Tato rodina kvantových circuit
může připravit rodinu kvantových stavů přibližujících základní stav.
Dále potřebujeme estimátor – prostředek pro odhadování střední hodnoty operátoru H nad aktuálním variačním
kvantovým stavem. Někdy nás opravdu zajímá jen tato střední hodnota, kterou
nazýváme nákladová funkce. Jindy nás zajímá složitější funkce, která stále může být zapsána vycházejíc z
jedné nebo více středních hodnot.
A nakonec potřebujeme klasický optimalizátor – algoritmus, který mění parametry, aby se pokusil minimalizovat tuto nákladovou funkci.
Pojďme nastínit problém, který chceme vyřešit, a obecný přístup, než se budeme zabývat tím, jakou roli hraje kvantový počítač. Mnoho
optimalizačních problémů zásadních pro vědu a průmysl lze formulovat jako maticové problémy. Obvykle chceš
minimální eigenhodnnotu své matice a eigenvector, který jí odpovídá. Matice H by mohla být
Hamiltonián popisující energii fyzikálního systému. A minimální eigenhodnota by byla energie základního stavu
E0 a eigenvector by byl odpovídající kvantový základní stav, často označovaný ψ sub0.
Nebo by matice mohla popisovat složitou nákladovou funkci spojenou s kombinatorickými optimalizačními problémy
jako v logistice, a eigenstav s_subopt by byl optimálním řešením
problému, jako je binární řetězec označující řez v grafu distribuční sítě. V praxi je
běžné slyšet termín Hamiltonián pro všechny matice zájmu, i mimo fyzikální vědy. Řekněme,
že nás zajímá matice s n řádky a n sloupci. Takové problémy lze řešit rychle a přesně pomocí
klasických solverů pro n do několika set nebo tisíc bez předpokladů o matici. Pro řídké
matice – ty s převážně nulami jako prvky – to může být mnohem větší, s n až miliarda i na laptopu.
Ale pro skutečně obrovské problémy přesahující tato čísla jsou často potřeba přibližné nebo heuristické metody.
Čím větší matice a čím méně řídká, tím méně zvladatelný problém a tím více chytrých triků musí být použito. Předpokládejme, že tvá matice je tak
velká, že přesná diagonalizace není možnost. Předpokládejme dále, že o svém problému víš dost, aby sis mohl
udělat odhady o celkové struktuře cílového stavu, a chceš prozkoumat stavy podobné tvému
počátečnímu odhadu, zda jde ještě snížit tvá cena nebo energie. Toto je variační přístup a je to jedna z metod,
které se používají, když přesná diagonalizace na klasickém počítači není možností. Fungovalo by to takto.
Nejprve uděláš odhadovaný stav s některými parametry theta, které budeš měnit.
Ačkoli tento počáteční odhad může být náhodný, není to vhodné. Chceme použít znalosti o daném problému,
abychom náš odhad co nejvíce přizpůsobili.
Za druhé, vypočítáme střední hodnotu operátoru se systémem v tomto stavu.
Za třetí, změníme variační parametry a opakujeme.
Za čtvrté, použijeme nahromadděné informace o krajině možných stavů ve tvém variačním podprostoru, abychom dělali stále lepší
odhady a přibližovali se cílovému stavu.
Variační princip zaručuje, že náš variační stav nemůže vydat eigenhodnotu nižší než
základní stav. Takže čím nižší střední hodnota, tím lepší je naše aproximace základního stavu. Pojďme
si promluvit o obtížnosti každého kroku v tomto přístupu.
Nastavení nebo aktualizace parametrů je výpočetně snadné. Obtíž spočívá ve výběru užitečných fyzikálně
motivovaných počátečních parametrů. Použití nahromaděných informací z předchozích iterací k aktualizaci parametrů tak,
aby ses přiblížil základnímu stavu, není triviální. Ale klasické optimalizační algoritmy existují, které to dělají
docela efektivně. Tato klasická optimalizace je nákladná pouze proto, že může vyžadovat mnoho
iterací. V nejhorším případě může počet iterací růst exponenciálně s n.
Výpočetně nejnákladnějším jednotlivým krokem je téměř jistě střední hodnota tvé matice pro daný
stav. Matice n×n musí působit na vektor o n prvcích, což odpovídá řádu n na druhou
operacím násobení v nejhorším případě. To musí být provedeno při každé iteraci parametrů. Pro extrémně
velké matice to má vysoké výpočetní náklady. Teď si představ, že tuto část
výpočtu přenecháš kvantovému počítači. Místo výpočtu této střední hodnoty ji odhaduješ připravením
stavu s(theta) na kvantovém počítači pomocí tvého variačního ansatz a pak prováděním měření.
Pojďme to trochu rozebrat. H se obecně snadno neměří. Například by mohl být složen z mnoha
nekomutujících Pauliho operátorů x, y a z.
Ale H lze zapsat jako lineární kombinaci členů H_subalpha, z nichž každý je snadno měřitelný. Například
Pauliho operátory nebo skupiny bitově komutujících Pauliho operátorů. Střední
hodnota H nad stavem s je váženým součtem středních hodnot složkových členů H_alpha.
Tento výraz platí pro jakýkoliv stav s, ale my ho budeme konkrétně používat s naším variačním stavem s(theta).
Každý z členů h_alpha lze měřit m-krát, přičemž dostaneme vzorky měření s_subalpha_j s j běžícím od
1 do m, a vrátí střední hodnotu a směrodatnou odchylku. Tyto
členy pak sečteme a propagujeme chyby přes součet.
To nevyžaduje žádné rozsáhlé násobení ani žádný proces, který by nutně rostl jako n na druhou. Místo toho
to vyžaduje více měření na kvantovém počítači. Pokud jich nepotřebuješ příliš mnoho, tento přístup by mohl být
efektivní. A to je kvantová část VQE. Ale pojďme si říct, proč to nemusí být efektivní. Jedním důvodem pro
mnoho měření je snížení statistické nejistoty v tvých odhadech pro výpočty s velmi vysokou přesností.
Dalším důvodem je počet Pauliho řetězců potřebných k pokrytí celé tvé matice. Protože Pauliho matice plus
identita pokrývají prostor všech operátorů dané dimenze, máme zaručeno,
že naši matici zájmu lze zapsat jako vážený součet Pauliho operátorů, jak jsme udělali dříve. Zde C_alpha je
numerický koeficient a H_alpha je řetězec Pauliho operátorů působící na všechny qubity popisující tvůj systém.
H_alpha by měl tvar jako tento, kde n-tý Pauliho operátor zprava působí na n-tý qubit. Takže můžeme
měřit náš operátor měřením série Pauliho operátorů. Ale nemůžeme měřit všechny tyto Pauliho operátory
současně. Pauliho operátory vyjma identity nekomutují navzájem, pokud jsou
přiřazeny ke stejnému qubitu. Například můžeme měřit I Z IIZ a ZZ
XZ současně, protože pro třetí
qubit můžeme měřit I a Z současně. A pro první qubit můžeme znát I a X současně. Ale nemůžeme
měřit všechna Z a ZZ ZX současně, protože Z a X nekomutují
a obě působí na nultý qubit.
Takže rozkládáme naši matici H na součet Pauliho operátorů působících na různé qubity.
Některé prvky tohoto součtu lze měřit najednou. Nazýváme to skupina komutujících Pauliho operátorů. Podle toho,
kolik nekomutujících členů existuje, můžeme potřebovat mnoho takových skupin. Počet takových skupin komutujících
Pauliho operátorů nazvěme t.
Pokud je ngcp malé, může to fungovat dobře.
Pokud má h miliony skupin, nebude to užitečné. Zaznamenáš střední hodnotu nebo nákladovou funkci
pro sadu parametrů theta použitou ve tvém stavu a pak parametry postupně aktualizuješ. Mohl bys použít
střední hodnoty nebo hodnoty nákladové funkce, které jsi odhadl, abys aproximoval gradient tvé nákladové funkce v
podprostoru stavů vzorkovaných tvým ansatz.
Existují jak klasické optimalizátory založené na gradientu, tak bez gradientu. Oba trpí potenciálními problémy s trénovatelností, jako jsou
mnohočetná lokální minima a velké oblasti parametrického prostoru s téměř nulovým gradientem, nazývané barren plateaus.
Vyřeší tedy VQE všechny tvoje nejtěžší problémy? Ne. Ale cílem nikdy nebylo být lepší ve všech výpočtech. Změnili jsme
to, co určuje výpočetní náklady. Podívej se, co jsme vyměnili. Přešli jsme od procesu,
jehož složitost závisí pouze na rozměru matice, k procesu, který závisí na požadované přesnosti a počtu
nekomutujících Pauliho operátorů tvořících matici. Poslední část nemá analogii v klasickém výpočtu.
Na základě těchto nových závislostí – pro řídké matice nebo matice zahrnující málo nekomutujících Pauliho řetězců – by tento
proces mohl být užitečný. To platí pro systémy interagujících spinů. Například pro husté matice může být
méně užitečný. Víme například, že chemické systémy mají často Hamiltoniány zahrnující stovky, tisíce, dokonce
miliony Pauliho řetězců. Bylo provedeno zajímavé dílo na snížení tohoto počtu členů, ale
chemické systémy mohou být lépe vhodné pro některé jiné algoritmy, o kterých si povíme v tomto kurzu.
Efektivní využití VQE také vyžaduje, abychom znali atributy našeho cílového stavu a mohli vybrat dobrý fyzikálně
motivovaný počáteční stav, stejně jako dobrý ansatz s relativně malým počtem variačních parametrů. To může být
docela náročné. VQE ukazuje, jak lze kombinovat silné stránky klasických a kvantových počítačů
bez přidávání novějších metod. VQE nám nepomáhá řešit problémy, které jsou nezvládnutelné pro klasické počítače, ale
nadále hraje roli ve vývoji algoritmů. A VQE nás také učí, že přenesení kroku z klasického
na kvantový počítač není ani lepší, ani horší pro všechny účely. Spíše
mění to, jaké faktory určují efektivitu tvého algoritmu. Toto je důležitá obecná lekce v
kvanto-klasickém hybridním výpočtu.